كانوا يحفرون خندقا قبل ان يبدا القصف بين
هؤلاء الجنود الاوكرانيين وقوه فاجنر
الروسيه في بخموت مسافه السته كيلومترات
فقط ومعارك لا سقفا زمنيا لها يحتاجون الى
يومين لانهاء الحفر تمت دائما روايتان لا
تتشابهان بشان خريطه القتال ومن يسيطر على
ماذا في بخموت التي باتت محور المعارك في
حرب دخلت عامها الثاني دون منتصرين او
منهزم تتحدث وزاره الدفاع الروسيه عن قصف
وحداتها منشات عسكريه اوكرانيه خلال الليل
واصابه كل الاهداف كما تواصل تقدمها في
بخموت على النقيض جاء كلام نائبه وزير
الدفاع الاوكراني التي قالت ان القوات
الروسيه فشلت في السيطره على بخموت وان
القتال مستمر كما تمكنت قوات بلادها من
استعاده بعض المواقع هناك
لا احد يمكنه التاكيد او النفي في حرب
البيانات والتصريحات بشان من يتقدم ومن
يتراجعوا وما هي النسب الحقيقيه لسيطره كل
طرف على الارض يبقى ثابت منذ شهور ان اليد
العليا وحتى هذه اللحظه لموسكو ومجموعه
التي تتهم وزاره الدفاع الروسيه بالتقاعس
في امدادها بالسلاح المطلوب منذ فتره مره
اخرى وجه قائد المجموعه انتقادات لاذعه
للمؤسسه العسكريه الروسيه اوضح ان قوته
لديها ما بين عشره وخمسه عشر في المئه فقط
من القذائف التي تحتاج اليها توقع ان تشن
القوات الاوكرانيه هجوما مضادا منتصف
الشهر الجاري يمكن ان يكون ماساه لروسيا
كثفت موسكو خلال الساعات الماضيه قصفها
الصاروخي على كييف ومناطق في الشمال
والشرق والوسط من جهتها افادت السلطات
الاوكرانيه بصد دفاعاتها الجويه المضاده
للصواريخ عده هجمات دون ذكر تفاصيل اخرى
من تفاصيل الحرب المؤلمه على جميع الاطراف
جنازات ضحايا القصف والغارات هذا حداد
اومان في وسط البلاد على مقتل ثلاثه
وعشرين مدنيا اموال الغرب واسلحته
وعقوباته لم تهزم موسكو وكل جندي وترسانه
روسيا العسكريه لم تحقق النصر المبين وما
دامت الحرب بلا هوادا ولا نهايه محتمله
مواكب الجنازات الكثيره لن تتوقف هنا
وهناك ايضا